[Musik]
größer ich bin der oberstoff meister
schmidt mario bin seit 2007 von platz 14
in der berge gruppe tätig die
wichtigkeit unseren rechts
geländegängige schwerlasttransport
system 70 tonnen vorstellen dass handelt
sie dabei bei der zugmaschine um eine
kooperation von immerhin und rheinmetall
das ist ein fortkommen relativ der
einspritzer mit 608 ps und einen simaks
aufleger von der firma dull das heißt
wir kindern insgesamt 70 jahren in lohne
das heißt unser gesamter höchst
zulässige gesamtmasse beträgt 130 tonnen
und mir von panzern 14 4 und damit
unsere schwersten dies ist der leopard 2
kampfpanzer und in berge benzema 88
und jetzt sciaroni ums vortag und die zu
recht ist genau so im vorjahr haus
befinden sich an brett drei sitze das
weiß damit der kraftfahrer arme danke
hilfe und arbeite vollzeit kommandant
die haupt verschiedene bedienelemente
das ist einmal das bedienelement führen
für ein auflieger lokal die reifen
drückte ob lesen lokale die
verschiedenen vor niveau sicherstellen
dass sich ja wollen
der aufleger entwicklung ist und mit
ling top-torhüter die anzeigen gibt noch
eine fernbedienung lokale unabhängig von
der zugmaschine war und daneben tritt
bis 20 km eingeschaltet wird keine
unabhängig von der zugmaschine mit
lenken dann habe ich eine
funkfernbedienung vor sind wir wirklich
in ober geht dann kann man da der
vorzeit kommandant von außen
unterstützen
ich habe zwar funkgeräte dass sie immer
eine verbindung habe zu meinem lotsen
vor zeigt weil es ist ja ein
sondertransport da braucht einen lotsen
vor zeigt dann muss die verbindung habe
ich hab da eine handykamera dieser am
aufleger hinten um eine kamera und
anna-carina umschalten dass sie
praktisch am schwanen häuschen
so haben wir zwar selber endnoten mit
jeweils 25 tonnen zugkraft von der firma
russland ist ein zwei spielen denken
dann geht es weiter da oben haben wir
den zusätzlichen hartz mutter für die
dass sie praktisch die hydraulik ohne
zugmaschine betreiben kann
darin sahen tor verschiedene stark
hessen führen aufleger so hammer die
raupen die hydraulisch zum betätigen
sein unten drin haben wir die stützen
weil bauen ihren browser auf logis
abgestützt sein und da aber nur den
bedientasten für die hydraulik für den
aufleger sowie ab manometer herren für
die landkreise anzeige für die brücke
bar oder tonnen
und das ist eigentlich im verbindungen
hat mutter oben ist herrn stück vom auch
immer ich kann ja wie gesagt die achsen
separat linken konto ein spuren weil es
ist es so dass die ersten zwei achsen
gelingt sein die dritte achse ist ua und
die restlichen vier linken auch mit so
langweilig wie die verlosung praktisch
ausschaut und für die es braucht man
natürlich an leopard unternehmer
[Musik]
die
hinter mir steht der kampfpanzer leopard
2 4 der ist mit 25 tonnen das schwerste
waffensystem im österreichischen
bundesheer die hauptwaffe ist die 120
millimeter kanone die sekundäre hoffnung
sind 27 62 mm maschinengewehre
die besatzung besteht aus vier personen
der panzerfahrer der lage schütze der
rechtsschütze und der panzer konnte das
ist der berge bahn 288 was in österreich
im bundesheer zum bergen und abschleppen
von chf bzw festgesessen fahrzeugen ja
genommen wird hat 50 tonnen eigengewicht
vier mann besatzung und wir doch zu viel
stand sitzung her genommen
es gibt zwar möglichkeiten wie man dann
zu fall ohne k entweder vor aus eigener
kraft oder wie in unserem 24 davon berge
fahren zu bruch der dort hergestellt und
wird mit den zwei servietten rausgezogen
für die es mir so ein bisserl doktor
umbauarbeiten wochen beim tier flora ob
ich dazu
[Musik]
nur das neue schwerlasttransport system
70 tonnen hat des aktuellen 14 eine sehr
wichtige logistische fähigkeit
zurückgewonnen hier nun einige jahre
zivil aus lager mussten mit den
schwerlasttransport system 70 tonnen
können hier rasch anfahren zur innerhalb
österreichs aber auch zu internationalen
prüfungen verlegen
natürlich kann auch der bergepanzer im
88 fragt sich an jeden ort österreich
verbracht worden und zum fest unter
zukunft hätten rasch vor ort eingesetzt
werden damit haben wir nicht den
militärischen nutzen sondern auch wenn
in weiteren nutzen hier die
katastrophenhilfe in besonderem umfang
durch das wäre das transportsystem haben
wir auch moderne lkw technik in den
verpackungen und sind damit auch mit
unseren deutschen partnern wieder auf
dem kirchentag mission niveau
dies hilft es ja bei den internationalen
ausbildungs und übungsformen die das
paar zwar um 15 läufern durch die
[Musik]